Holy shit guys, EVO 2018 is in the books and that's a wrap for the world's biggest fighting game tournament.
There were moments that gave us goosebumps.
(Casting)
And others that made us laugh.
In fact, we've got an entire video for you guys just dedicated to those fails and funny moments from Evolution this year,
but this video... this video is about the best of the best.
I'm talking about the cream of the crop from the most incredible pop-offs
(Casting)
To improbable comebacks.
And of course the filthiest of combos,
(Casting)
Here is the best of EVO 2018.
Well guys, you know what they say.
It's never over until it's over.
Even when you're down in rounds, down in games and
facing an opponent who clearly has the download on you, with just a pixel of health magic can happen.
Here are some of our favorite comebacks from EVO 2018.
(Casting)
Look guys, EVO is the grandest stage of them all and competition nerves can hurt execution.
But if you do get the chance to bust out that lab tech on stream, why not right?
(Casting)
Okay guys, so far we've seen some sick plays and some filthy combos but what would those be without the pop-offs to match?
Guys, EVO is a meat grinder.
World-class players drown in pools.
Relative unknowns make it to greatness in Top 8 and upsets do happen.
Here are some of our favorites from this year's Evolution.
(Casting)
Another year, another EVO guys and man, this one was sick. I mean Problem-X with the Bison, Leffen finally winning
Melee, and of course the Evo debut of Dragon Ball FighterZ.
Makes me want to watch it all over again. And if you agree hit that replay button and let's go.